shut the door
get me some water though come back jesus
christ
yes you're i'm a man i asked you to do
something you're a woman you go and you
do it you don't ask
questions
i got married three years ago and i'm
not lonely too much now anymore and i
got a good woman i say it i got a woman
who loves me for my money and my fame
and not for what i am
and you and your wife wasn't impressed
you were saying yeah i came home and i
showed her all these offers and it's
good you guys are paying really good
money
like it's i don't even care the comics
yeah i don't have a tv
job right now so that's that's my income
yeah and i showed it to her and she's
like yeah great
so you're going out of town leaving me
with the kids i'm like [ __ ] you you
how much money do you make what are you
pulling in uh this week
yeah would you rather starve to death
and [ __ ] let the kids get skinny you
[ __ ] ungrateful
[ __ ] now the only way that does it who
doesn't listen
she doesn't quite get the point that you
know this is your job you don't yeah
and i'm remembering the phrase the
separation of labor is that what it is
the division of labor contract
has been thrown away in marriage because
i know where you're going to go with
this
but i got to ask louis ck yeah like when
you
married your wife you were already in
comedy right yes i was so it's not like
you were
i didn't spring it on her no it wasn't
like you're working for nassau you had a
nine-to-five job you were coming home
and she knew what she was getting into
that you'd be there to raise the kids
you when you guys met she knew you were
a road cop yes yes
but the way it's not even that i go on
the road the point is that i enjoy
my job right so she thinks of it that
because it's not like i'm going out and
slack she wishes i was doing a miserable
job and then she would be proud of me
come home yeah in order to put a roof
over the head but the fact that i do
something that i'm proud of that i love
doing
and but it still puts a roof over the
head but because women's
liberation that because there are women
that have
careers we're not allowed to say that we
are
providers anymore if you're a man but
the fact is my wife
lives off of my [ __ ] work and doesn't
do [ __ ]
so if she had a career then she could go
yeah [ __ ] you with your open anthony
tour i don't care i'm working too
yeah i got mine but the fact is she just
eats food that i
buy for her but i'm not allowed to point
that out or else i'm a male chauvinist
like i'm i'm being a like backwards pig
by pointing out
of the fact which is that if i stop
doing these
fun tours where i might get blown by a
[ __ ] or two
that she can't eat that she can't eat
anything because if she
tried to start making a she's worthless
she has no
sense of she she couldn't she could
never support our house
she could know it if we switched places
it would like some dumb sitcom
right uh the kids would be very happy
with me because i'm good at taking care
of the kids and be the fun guy hanging
around and my wife would be
unable to [ __ ] yeah hold down the job
she's never done it
really she worked in a chinese
restaurant for one week
and the way the the woman who owned this
chinese woman said to her
uh how come you so slow oh she said
because i'm
busy how many tables you have and she
said i have
three tables and she said i think you
may be nobody waitress
and she fired her that's how you get
fired and asian yeah
i'll tell you i can't relax you know the
other night i was in a place i felt like
having a few drinks someone
in a bartender i said surprise me he
showed me a naked picture of my wife
sometimes my wife gets mad at me for
behaving wrong in her dreams
that ain't fair
i had a horrible dream last night you
want to hear about it no i'm going to
tell you anyway
a grizzly bear was chasing me through
the woods with his teeth he was going to
eat me
and you did nothing
[Applause]
you just sat there and you didn't do a
thing
what was i doing you were playing poker
with a rabbit that's what you were doing
and that's the thing you would do
something like that you would play poker
with a rabbit
well i was being eaten by a bear luckily
a giant unicorn came and saved me
with his laser horn that's how i saved
not by you
okay the truth and my wife and i we
never have sex now we can undress we
can't stop laughing
[Laughter]
but i'll tell you what my wife does have
sex she screams oh especially when i
walk in on it
[Music]
shut the door go get me some water
though come back
jesus christ yes you're i'm a man i
asked you to do something you're a woman
you go and you do it you don't ask
questions
[Laughter]
oh god so anyways like i was saying
they're sitting there [ __ ] moaning and
complaining about all the stuff
they don't have but we you know and it's
like
you [ __ ] outlive us you outlive us
what are you giving me water for in a
shot glass
come on nia don't be a douche
well you know what you have a birthday
coming up i know exactly what i'm
getting you
big bag of fritos you're an [ __ ]
[Laughter]
put it in a juice glass
all right so anyways yeah so they're
always [ __ ] mothering and complaining
about what they don't have right you
know do they have a look around and see
what they do have
a whole [ __ ] platoon of shoes
huh that that guy paid for i'll tell you
what i have
right oh snap
12-6 right there baby
hey man you know why i make more an hour
than you
because i'm better than you because i'm
worth more than you
think about it nia think about all the
great inventions
think about all the great stuff that
makes your life simple
has a broad invented one of them
as any of them stop running their yap
for more than three seconds to even
invent the [ __ ] can
opener you know what that's
actually a great question let's go to
broadinventions.org
let's see let's see what the ladies
women i'm going to tell you something
inventors
okay i'm gonna tell would you guys
invent skippy peanut butter
marie curie huh you know what your mic's
turned down for a reason
all right here we go women inventors
yeah we are so lame you know famous
famous how [ __ ]
lame you are with this [ __ ] premise
that you have i know
i know i know how fat i am many years of
your career
you've been squeezing this dumb premise
drive for the last 10 years of your
career what are you having time to move
on
okay we have a brand new move on what
are you having for breakfast a nice big
bowl of feminism
yeah well you know what that that
[ __ ] uh chauvinism paid for that
bowl of feminism famous women inventors
oh good are you actually gonna learn
something and not talk out of your ass
oh absolutely yeah this is gonna be a
quick read
no it's not actually look at all these
people here it's like 12 names
you're going to fall asleep before you
get there's more guys on the clippers
than those [ __ ] women and fenders
mary anderson
barbara askins that takes care of the
a's
patricia billings marion donovan
sally fox well what the [ __ ]
do you think i'm serious yes
let's see mary anderson anyone who's
ever driven in a rain or a snow storm
really needs to get a new bed though
you really need to get a new bed what
are you talking about you know what i'm
talking about
what try i didn't trash women once my
last special you're
i didn't but what's happening right now
you still come and wait you circle in
the wagon back around the same guys
i have the sniffles i don't feel good
this is comfort food for me
oh this is comforting to you oh you know
what you know something's going on
wait wait wait so wait sad wait wait
okay miss
enlightened miss enlightened what did
mary anderson invent
i don't know oh yeah he claimed to know
what did barbara askins
invented i don't know they'll post it
how about patricia billings i don't
you call yourself a feminist and you
don't know your starting lineup
that's not this you want me to name the
[ __ ] patriots offensive line because
i'll [ __ ] do it
no i really don't sally fox do anything
regarding sports uh yeah i i don't
know what just because that doesn't mean
that i would know
every female for that doesn't make any
sense but
you know you don't know any of them how
about
how about barry invented graham did
marie curie
invented i'm gonna name all the names on
this list and i want you to tell me what
one of them did dr
temple grandin oh oh yes uh
she was the woman who invented the thing
for
cows so when they were going to
slaughter they wouldn't be freaking out
like sort of like a little pressurized
thing that's on them
because she had like autism or something
like that you got some of it the thing
that usually amazes people about
most about prolific woman inventor dr
temple grandin is not all the great
strides she has made to improve
animal handling devices you nailed it
nor the fact that she earned a phd in
animal science
why is that amazing you know what
is such a [ __ ] douchebag
even when it's in front of your face in
black and white like well i don't like
how when you guys
i'm sick of you why when you guys do
[ __ ] that we do it's suddenly amazing
you know what
you you know i like you come on you're
being a baby about this
i'm not being a baby you're being an
adult i'm breaking my balls you're
getting all fresh down there
i uh i know who she is because there was
an hbo movie about it
starring oh there you go thank you can't
sit down and read
all right really bill what was the last
book you you read
and [ __ ] stephen adler's biography
doesn't count
i think that might have been the last
one i read the uh
fairy 2014 book um
all right whatever so you know so they
you guys you know you got a nice little
list here
what i can't believe you felt the need
to go online
as if to somehow wait did women invent
things like what is wrong with you
you i really had to keep asking that
question hey is it because you're a 46
year old white man from boston like is
that can i really just distill it down
to your stats can i ask you a question
to you no you can't i want you to name
some women inventors
temple grading i keep saying marie curie
didn't she
invented yeah you're talking all this
[ __ ] like i can't believe blah blah blah
blah but you don't even have the
you don't even have the bullets in your
gun you're over there you're shooting
blank
i don't need to have bullets in my i
know you don't all you got to do is
start
bitching and everybody listens to you
because i'm smart enough sometimes
you're
abroad you're the one going online like
a prehistoric
don't blow your nose into the microphone
jesus how are you still
sick anyway she knows she's wrong
because i'm up all night trying to find
something you guys did
if anybody takes this [ __ ] seriously
go [ __ ] yourselves
you know somebody's gonna take a little
clip of this and set it to some clambake
[ __ ]
site and i'll get in trouble yeah
whatever the [ __ ] they are